Well, unfortunately for me, I was never
particularly interested in money, so in
hindsight it was just smarter, but I
played tennis because of money, that
was never a motivating factor if you wanted to
win, to become normal, but
I just wanted to become one with winning
and whether  I then earn something or
not was always secondary now you can
say, easy to say, at 17
I already had my first million but I forgot
some of the prize money so I
forgot the check when I came to you but
the animals didn't come at all or in my
mother and always  We still have to okay, can
you do that? Welcome
to the OMR podcast today. Something
unusual setting. We are in a
hotel in Munich but we have very
lively guests and also a very
specific occasion, so there is the big
baker podcast on the occasion of
the US Open coming up  So in New York
that's something you have to comment on,
it's not entirely new but on Sport
Deutschland TV it's a
streaming offer from Germany that
you didn't necessarily know that well until now
but now it's getting big and
Björn is one of them
Shareholder under managing director
halbejörn half hello, greetings so let's
start with the obviously
current why did you buy the rights to
a US Open why were you
able to convince Boris but we were
able to convince you together with a
team that you should
comment on  a German
streaming service, no, not that well-known, yes,
maybe we'll be at the forefront for a short time.
Sport Deutschland TV, you said
not yet that well-known for the big rights,
so we're definitely known in the niche,
always in individual cases in judo, sometimes
in wrestling, but in handball  In the
last few years we have also held a lot of
world championships and
European championships and in the
last year and a half the
construct of society has
changed, the structure has given us the opportunity to simply
tackle other topics that we
consider to be economically sensible and that we
have  A few months ago we
acquired the Ice Hockey World Cup exclusively and
now the US Open and um I think
that's a big step so
briefly about the genesis sportdeutsche TV was
once founded by
the Sportbund, I think that's right
and then you'll have that at some point
I think it was taken over by them and then you had
some employee who then
bought ProSieben, that's
pretty much it, so the Germany
Olympic Sports Confederation founded the company,
I think in 2013,
deusb new media GmbH with the aim of
medializing sports outside of football  In 2015, ProSieben
Sat.1 became the majority shareholder,
we
took over the majority back then and at the end of 2021,
as managing director of the 7 years I
was in there, I
bought out the entire company and am
now with private investors, so to speak
USB Media invests
ProSieben is no longer included under the
USB and no longer how big is the
company
this year brown about 6 million and
growing rapidly okay um and employees
we now have 14 permanent employees
but we work a lot with
freelancers I have to say right now  with
editors with graphic designers and so
on so the entire team is
certainly over 30 people and provides
the information or any kind of
references to your subscribers or or
users who from the month onwards
surprisingly like everyone else
doesn't but that's very important we
have of course
We don't have any subscribers at all, we don't have a subscription structure, that's very
important: we're not a subscription
model, we're not a person, not Sky
or not yours, but our model
is completely different. First of all, there's a lot of
content for free and the paid content
is always on  Package bound that
as a user you only buy what
you want to see. Example US Open you
buy a ticket now for 20 €
once you can see all matches of the US Open
or with us you can
buy a league for a
season  and nothing else, but just
content always means marketing as a
business and you are for yourself
or the mixture of how much is advertising money
and how much is not subscribers
but then
pay fees, so to speak, only
got into the pay business in 22 and has  It's
now getting a lot better, so we're
now at I would say almost 65 70
percent pay compared to marketing,
okay, the advertising market is difficult
anyway, especially for everyone involved, you have to
say one more reason to play the pay issue,
but I think it has to
play cleverly that's why we're a
big fan of these event passes and
team passes and so on, okay
understood but not an easy market either,
we see problems for Sky
to make money over the years so
also with a different model but
still there is one  a bit like the
space now comes Mr. Seifert with
your um also there are great
expectations but also total doubts about how
well it will go then various
other providers who are doing it easily
now you said around 6
million euros in sales is enough to get it
Financing Boris, let alone
up here, well, that was
the budget planning before the US Open,
you have to say that because when did we
plan the US Open, that was
in May this year, let's say it was
ready that we
could really take part in the pitch  Yes, May 2023 if
you want, that's pretty much it,
of course, you
're well connected in the rights market,
you know which right
will come onto the market and when. At the US Open, it's so
that in recent years they have always been
awarded across Europe to Eurosport
and now they have been
advertised separately for Germany and
we noticed that and
of course we took part in the pitch
and in the end we were impressed with a good concept
but we bought it five years ago
so they don't do a small calculation
exactly. I think that shows that
we really put in the effort  When it came to the
concept, we had really
creative ideas and presented the topic in a really
different way in order to convince the USA
because it is a
traditional tournament, we are talking about the
Grand Slam. A UCI will
not decide lightly who to give the right to,
so you have to decide  Making it clear for
them is also a big risk because
they really want prominence and
relevance and to be better known for their sport
and if there is now
a German niche player
then the question is why are
they doing it and what does it have?  Convincing
in the end, apart from money, I think
our overall concept in terms of the breadth of what
we plan to do in the next
five years and we are showing that
here too, that we have a Boris with us, that
we have really brought together the elite of commentators and
experts  to
all broadcasters that we
show the range, that we
show all matches from the juniors to the
qualification to the wheelchair to the doubles
to the mixed all that of course we
also work with German television stations
in various
areas. I think the concept in the end
convinced you to say we're going
This path because
tennis or sport as a whole is
moving in this direction and
the UCI is now really at the forefront with the US Open
and let's say a
very rough one to get that but
quite a year but that's it  in the
mid seven-figure range or
that's as you can imagine,
I'm not allowed to talk about it but
of course it's a right that um and
I say that quite openly that it's
worth what we pay, we clearly see it
that way and that's it  Break even in the first year, so
you can
make money with it in the first year. To be honest, it's
not our goal at all. I'll
of course be happy if we
manage to do it, but of course we now have a
budget in the short-term
budget
Investment planned we
see that we
probably have to invest in the first two years you
have a lot of background noise that you have in the
first few years then we send the
team to New York we are somehow
in New York with 12 people etc. we
built a studio and so on  further that means
break even in the first year, nice if we can
do that but it doesn't have to be we
are ready to invest in the first few
years and then in the end to be really big
okay okay how many viewers or
how much say buyers in the end you have to
have the question  It always comes up,
you have to have it, of course
I can't communicate the number,
but you can imagine that we
have planned our budgets, our
expectations and I'll say it all, we
're in the six-figure range with
sales, we're convinced how
many of them  In the end there is a lot of
good marketing, a lot of good input
from our experts and so on and
then there is the free component.
We are certainly in the
seven-figure range in terms of users,
which we show at other events, including
a Handball World Cup, etc
Will we be able to get 1.5 2.5 million people on the platform?
We will do that at the US Open, no, but
of course you have them there first.
100,000 and then I
noticed in advance of the research that it
costs 20 euros  Then you can
watch the tournament as a whole, which
at 100,000 would be around 2
million euros in sales that you would make
with the pay, there it is
when you ask yourself the cost of flying to New York,
fees, not that much air
actually in it, exactly that's why  I said
six figures, that could
be 999,000 tickets, but we're all
careful with the numbers we
put out, but I think the experience
we've had over the last few years
in terms of pay, um, that's the basis for what
we're planning to do here
We've done surveys, analyzes and so on,
so we're very confident about it.
I would say that we can generate that
in the next few years,
recorded as a room or normal,
no, we actually
did it within the society,
so the society there are there directly  We
were convinced, we are only three
partners with Thomas Riedel, Sven
Brandt and I, we
sat down together, it was a
decision from the operational side and
Thomas Riedel is, so to speak, the
entrepreneur that you may know,
he says he organizes a lot of events technically
and please live with you
There's a larger company in Wuppertal
that's probably a bit of
cash in. I
imagine we've divided ours quite well, I think, in
the corporate structure
percent each and we invest in it together
but of course the topic is that
Thomas at the top also goes ahead
and says I'm behind it and I
believe in the concept that has been in place for the
last year and a half and is the same
now, so the US Open as
To take an example, I think it took us about
72 hours after the
concept was presented that we
decided among the shareholders
that this is the budget and that's what we're going to invest
in it and of course we know the risk
you actually via
video call so first you need a
presentation my team built a big
presentation for it I think I
had 14 15 pages where it says how
would we present the US Open because
the USA of course asked themselves the question. I
know Sky,
but I know Eurosport  Who is
sportdeutschland.tv So you imagine you are making
a concept, the USA and
the agency, which also
helped a lot and got us to the point
where we
could present this background
and in the end there were a few discussions
with us  the UCI that led to you
choosing us and what are you planning to do
now so how are so many people supposed to
hear about me having a
press conference here that's why we're
in Munich together today, of course Boris
has a reputation and relevance and
also social reach but what  are
you still doing it to activate the event, so to speak,
with you it's actually quite
exciting, I think that's in the 8
years in which I'm now
deospinemia is giving the second
press conference we gave,
the first was as ProSieben Sat.1
is and the second one is
full today when they got out there was
no press conference,
logically and you saw
how many people were here today so
what press was represented there were
really a lot of press representatives there but
apart from that we will first
cooperate with all tennis partners
which exists in Germany we will
work in the German tennisbon we work with the
big tennis players we work
with all of them in the tennis magazine we
of course Borussia will
run our own campaigns a lot about social
of course we are also talking
about a big car of campaign that
could come we are talking  about TV, so we
want to tell the tennis changer outside
here it starts, yes the us, for
example, Germany TV,
of course, when the US Open starts,
Google also does a pretty good job technically
because we hold the exclusive rights and
we ultimately use the highlights
as the fastest of all
and I think about the ways if we
can tell a lot of people about it, okay, how
many people always watched when
Eurosport was running in the free because you know that
you apparently
exactly so I don't know, I
saw that with them  French Open
also very much in Grand Slam there was the
quarter-finals of 12 years, I think
on average 450,000 in the top 700 I
think we had like around 800,000 at the Grand Slams
can of course depend on it if it were
somehow playing semi-finals you have  yes
again a table football, the nice thing about
tennis is also a
decision that we have taken into account.
First of all there is the tennis fan who wants to
see tennis, he also wants to
see Joko and Alcaras and in the end there is
the tennis fan who only comes up a little bit
the general
bonus I have then you have
earned a bit of money we always say
between ourselves that we should
n't even think about what would happen
if it were a semi-final game then it
is clear to us what happens then yes
you can see that then you will win an extra €1000
definitely yes  and it's realistic
semi-final
at some point a short answer yes he was
in the News open 2020 in the final against
Dominic Thiem in hindsight he should have
won that served for the
match 5:330 both two points
for the win it wasn't supposed to be there and uh
but  Basically, the farbglass is like being
on sand at home. He had this serious
ankle injury in Paris a year ago
and it took a long time until he was
back in shape, the physicality is the
self-confidence and I think
he'll be back at the latest since your music at the Red Tree two weeks ago  the
old man and now he plays in Canada and
of course everyone assumed that
the form would
be one of the favorites again to be one of the favorites at my US Open okay so
of course we will as I
was really excited myself this year for the first time
in Paris and Nuremberg
It's really fascinating, so
insofar as I press let's see,
you say somehow there
should be at least 100,000 viewers,
it would be easy,
they can somehow now, so
that means we have a normal 5
year contract and we will
stick to it on both sides  It's
contractually regulated but sublicensing
we actually have all the rights we
can also sublicense oh so
to speak if you
find someone who pays a lot of money
then you also make sure that their
abitrat wins if the ARD says so
man really semi-final then that's
one  Model the other model is just
that we also think about what
free TV means for us a free TV
means first of all more attention on
such a topic so of course you look
at who you can maybe work with and
bring even more attention to the topic but first of all it is  the case
is calculated as if we
show the event alone for five years. I somehow
also read a bit of research
that the US Open is not that easy,
partly because of the time difference
but also partly because
the Bundesliga is just starting in Germany and at the
beginning of the
Bundesliga players on it but that's what
you're saying is probably well, I want to
reach tennis fans and I'm interested
in the hardcore tennis fan who has
nothing to do with the Bundesliga in football, yes I
think a lot of tennis fans are still
football fans in some way but we have we're
talking  In New York it starts at
5 p.m. German time and we
play every day during the week,
so to speak, and in the end you
always reach the tennis falls when it comes to tennis,
but the fact that they also
watch football on the weekend is one but at 3 p.m  :30 p.m.
wouldn't be able to see much of the US Open either,
okay okay, so I'll keep my
fingers crossed for you if you
achieve seven-figure sales,
probably no, that seven-figure
sales isn't that, um, so that
wouldn't be the minimum to achieve
any seven-figure sales
Make sure that we're going to make you permanent
or something like that 5 million plus with the
tournament now then I'll come
back to you and say everything
worked okay okay okay so we've
talked about it no matter now who's
saying goodbye now I'll come a bit
to Boris I  I've been wishing for a long time that
we got to know each other a
few months ago in 19 Hamburg as part of
the festival, a new management
team a bit, but still,
so many
interviews have already been conducted with you, so
you can actually read and watch and  Books
and there is really endless material,
you say yourself that you have been a
public figure for almost 40 years now,
that is a bit of a problem that
a lot of old interviews and
conversations are still quoted, in
fact I admit it in the last one  two
three five years hardly any interviews
anymore so feel honored thank you
but in fact I have a trust
and we got off to a good start
in Hamburg on stage in May and
I think we worked out some pretty good topics
and sentences  still
came out well who because I me you are you
are tested you are prepared and
I often don't experience that with many colleagues who
then take the drawer from
92 or 97 or 2014 and then I
said this and this but the time
has increased enormously  has changed especially for
me in this respect I'm very positive what
I'm saying I wanted to ask in general how
has this topic of publicity changed from your point of view
so if
it's also the environment it's always a
topic of public reach when it
started with you the world was
already there  Also somehow a completely different one, there
was already the Bild newspaper, it's
still there today but otherwise almost
everything is different now there's Sport
Deutschland TV. Back then there were somehow
different channels, everything was different. What has
changed for you now about the dishwasher? So if  I talk about it with my
children, my there was
no internet then they look at me
like no internet yes no, March 20
years ago there was no internet there was no
cell phone there were two three day newspapers there
were two three channels 4 channels and  So that's it
the public has
changed dramatically by
becoming a multi-billion dollar business
internationally that has advantages and that
has disadvantages everything for you now more
disadvantages because you are constantly
being photographed by people somewhere when you
are in public it used to be
for  People who didn't see that
I was happy but didn't have a cell phone
with me today, there were no cameras at all, but there was
n't this social media reach,
it became more unpleasant for you
privately much more unpleasant professionally
much more interesting so I live
my brand my personality brand
that's called  Boris Becker and need the
public of course and need the
international public that's why
I benefit from it today privately it's
more of a disadvantage that you really
can't go anywhere anymore because everyone
has a cell phone and everyone has an iPhone
and takes a photo and can use it in the
Second on Twitter on Instagram or
or someone else sell it and so
the next morning or
sometimes in the night everyone knows where I
would be at dinner with who I would
say at the table but in
preparation for the conversation here
I somehow moved something briefly afterwards
off in the world and then looked straight
back into the story that you
were on holiday somehow in Italy there
isn't, um, that's
obviously allowed,
you're on the balcony for a bit of holiday and then
it's photographed and then
prepared as a message  That wasn't a
big news
but that's the hard
part. Actually, you don't have any rights
anymore and if you
're as well-known as me, anyone can
shoot you down and then sell it the next
day. The report about it was
completely hane  Büchen so there again
is the place, definitely the hotel and
something else. Yes, I was with my
partner on a terrace of a
hotel in Italy, that was definitely the case, the
rest was fine with me, only that it lasted for
three or four days because it was the so-called
summer slump  and then
questions come again and so on and so on,
it's really a loss of
privacy, it's like that and you have to
learn to protect yourself and that means
that you're even more careful,
more private and have an even smaller
environment than you  that maybe had for 5
or 10 years
is
so that you
can still trust people or something like that or how
trust is created so when you
human people
take photos of you somehow also with you business
always you have so many
different people too  in the environment
over the years they have
come back like we do you discover
how much do you create trust
I have lost trust per se but for
me what
counts is what you have done so if you
do what you say you want to do
then you already have one of those  little
trust bonuses and then it's
next week next month and I've often
had people in the field who
were close friends for 10 years and then
sold the story in the 11th year,
so that's often happened to me and I'm
a bit like that  dinosaura, as
I said, 40 years in the public
person and I have experienced everything
that you can imagine, even more so where
friends for a
handful of dollars, I call it,
have sold myself or our friendship and and those would have been
there  I won't name any names now, that's why
I don't trust anyone at first and
I have to build up this trust
over months or even years, but
I think it's important to have partners
you where you
can rub each other where you could sometimes their
opinion is now what the brand
has to be because with me you can't
forget so the German
positioning of Boris Becker is a
completely different international and
international German bigger like like
Germany  That's why I have to
ask myself how important is
the German market for me, which is
made in German, that is
Germany Austria Switzerland and
how important is America Asia Africa as
South America so you see English, people
talk about me significantly more in English  as in German so
I also have to position myself accordingly
so this as this
time where I find myself how I
find myself is far from over and I
just have to see that I
would be fair to my fans and my finely-intentioned international  Do
you think about choosing such
a publicity strategy from time to time
or are you annoyed that you did
n't choose it, like
Günther Jauch and Stefan Raab in
Germany, so you have chosen even
if you are
very present depending on the occasion and at your
shows and at  Otherwise, public events
here are completely
private and therefore better
protected. I don't think they are allowed to
be photographed in public so easily
because they, um, so to speak,
always prevented that immediately
or made it clear
that it wasn't their wish
and you did  a special one went or
was this this path not open at all I
would say in this path that is from
Jauch and have these people to go
I think the question was
not even asked as a 17 year old but
I suddenly became the property of the
Federal Republic of Germany and
everyone could everyone was allowed to want Boris Becker
and I think there was a
different girl's law and a different system
and I've definitely made
another public mistake in almost 40 years this year
but I do
n't think you can
turn back the clock  Yes, you
actually have to have the rights as a private citizen,
my wonderful
media lawyer Dr Moser says, no, you have
lost the rights, but
you lost the female ones 38 years ago by
simply being like I was, let's just say,
very open and very, very gullible
and  very, very
confidential towards friends and enemies
and then at some point there was a
limit that I
crossed at some point in my 20 years. I'm now in my mid-50s and
I can't talk back about it and
now with respect for Günter, yes
Also and Stefan Raab she doesn't know him in
America and
neither in Asia nor in Africa
so they have an easier private life because they can go abroad
wherever that is, I can't, we
sometimes don't realize that in German
that abroad
hopefully likes me and
respects me and knows me and
follows me just as much as Germany does and
and that there is significantly
greater resistance abroad there is
also a bit of a question about
your relationship to Germany, I would have that
in the in
I noticed a bit of research and it was
actually over quite quickly, in the
sense that you moved to Monaco from Leimen at an early age,
I think when you were
17, 18, 19
and then you were working all over the world,
obviously you had a
worldwide personality and you had friends
from all over the world
but your connection to Germany
still feels very strong, so
you've been appearing on German TV for
many years on a
wide variety of shows. You're still
more rooted here than you
could have expected from someone who was
15 years old  World goes and there are
also other examples of people who
actually never come back until today
Steffi Graf is hardly present here in Las
Vegas you know her example um is that
still the case with you that
Germany is somehow important to
you
so I'm with you  After secondary
school I emigrated to Monte
Carlo at the age of 16.
Why because my management,
my coach
lives in Monte Carlo, so do all the other
tennis players and first of all because it
was so nice to me and the
tennis courts are so beautifully red, so of course
Is it also for tax reasons only
at 16, I haven't earned anything yet,
so if you're the first step
if something happens, I had
advantages where I was 16 or 17, so that did
n't interest me there either, um, but
I still like Davis  Cup
played and and always enjoyed
playing in Germany and
Germany is still my
emotional home now I could have made it easier for myself
like a woodski like Steffi Graf and the
rest of us international German also
a Heidi Klum I want to mention they
are in  I went abroad and live there
and only come very
rarely on a project-related basis my week or
200 Germany and go back
I didn't make a
mistake, but I don't want to
deny myself and I like being in
Munich Frankfurt Hamburg or Berlin
and I still have  a few good
German friends and and like the
German culture and like my homeland
um I could have made it easier,
which is not the case now
I'll try to live it out a little more concentratedly in the future,
i.e.
if I now have a job in Munich
we today or  or in Frankfurt then
I'll be there for two days
doing my job and then go
back to my new home now that
Italy has become life in there and
try to protect myself better
than I did in the past,
you're following along with them  the young
players or the younger ones in the
generation after you, how they
build their brand, what kind of business they
do with our Roger Federer, it's
like that they never build
themselves as a brand worldwide,
you look at something like that, of course
I have to  Now I can also learn from the best
Roger and his management, they
do it excellently. Um,
of course, he doesn't have the ups and
downs that I had, but it
feels like it's one high after another
look at what
footballers do, how a
Schweinsteiger does it or a Toni great
does it, how my generation does it. I
think it was more difficult, so
the sporting consequences were a
long time ago, which is why I
still use the word relevance today
I like that I'm
still relevant today, I'm a bit
proud because that's essential for the brand,
you still have to have a role, a
meaning, a number,
and also internationally and I
'm trying to make better use of that today
than I did  I did that maybe five or
ten years ago, so the
relevance is now my claim,
but it is based, among other things, on the fact
that there was
a big Apple documentary about you just last year.
I think
there was a Netflix documentary about you two years before that  Life still
exists almost every day,
but it's talked about on the picture and
on other portals, you
're commenting on news about you up here, so that there's
still something there, too. I don't think I'm
the only one who feels the relevance that way,
but the
public always has questions too  I'm having
fun now when you see it with
eggesy for example or with Steffi Graf
at the time, it just felt funny, they
never wanted it, they had to
accept it as athletes as sports stars
but they were never actually looking for it and
even when it was over they went
diving  As best as I can, that's
my feeling, that was with you. You
already have that, you like to do it too. I feel
comfortable in public, that
means when I walk across a red
carpet, I don't scurry
over it or hide behind it, I
'm then  because my 10 or 15
minutes so I it's not
difficult for me I don't want to say that I'm
looking for it but also I'm
more careful with it today somehow because
it's often misinterpreted because of
the search that takes time no if me if
a sponsor has me  If a
film production or someone
invites me to an event then
I try to do justice to the invitation
and then I'm a professional and um I
think that's the case with Dirk or
Handwerk too
but they see more in America again
that's her  So Dirk is an
absolute superstar in America and always
lives in everything and when he goes to New
York or leaves then there
's a great news
about it but it's not reported that much here
and when Andreain goes to one of
his schools you founded it
or pursues his foundation or goes to eat
at Steffi Kraft Staple with his wife,
then that's a
story in America but it's
not conveyed in the same way in Germany
because there are of course a lot more big
stars in America and if so
Tom Cruise  in New York goes around the
houses or a Jamie Fox has
a greater reach as he
saw you there but actually you
are one of them almost came to say that
after you such a magnitude
has rarely been given and still you
accordingly  Generate clicks and
attention because there is
hardly anyone who
has this charisma so I
would like you to have more in
Munich Würzburg and he would have
an old one
and to distribute that a bit and um yes that's
what I mean  Life would be easier if there were
more German opportunities, also
of the international
scope, that would play a role here
when is that actually I
see that so I'm
not
arrogant about it now or or say I think I
'm incredibly great and so on
but it's simply a fact, it's
simply a situation
and if in my case if there are
no new stories there are
really 20 year old stories being
unpacked on the cover of the
various
tabloid magazines and the circulation is
made, I tell people that  is 20 years
old, what has happened in these 20
years that you are
still using me? Yes, I can
feel comfortable in it but also
embarrassed because there must be
more exciting things than
bakers, which is actually often the case
You really know the individual
people, we're talking about brands and
images and whatnot, but in the end
you probably also know the
individual editors who are
behind them and you also know them
personally or you know some of the
editors personally
Doing the same job for 20 years I do
n't want to judge whether it's good
or bad, but 20 years
means that time has stood still a bit
and that I have
n't been a tennis player for much longer than
I have and
very few people have registered tennis games, so I do  I've been working in
television since 2002 for
international broadcasters, not just
tennis but general sports and also
entertainment and here I'm
usually still the 17-year-old
leimena who
threw up the chocolate and so on, but I've
done so much more than just that
Played tennis and it wasn't all bad
but that's the drawer that's
somehow he hasn't found one yet in
Germany when when did it
slowly become clear to you that everything
could take on such a dimension, so when I was
17 years old I started playing sports
Everything
then went on and on and
there were defeats, but I think your sports
career as a person in their early 30s is
slowly coming to an end. Um, when on this
journey did you realize, okay, this is
now really big here and
not just so to speak,
yes, that took a long time  That did
n't happen overnight. I did
n't really realize that when I was 17 or 18,
even then during my
career I was so focused on
my sport, so we don't care about it
after my active career.
Yes, it never affected me either
I'm honestly interested in that, but I
tried to do my thing to the best of my knowledge
and belief and then it worked out
well sometimes not as well as with everyone
else.
I was more surprised
when I noticed the
waves  down so if I
make a double mistake like everyone else
then it's kind of the end of the world so
yes, but that's a double mistake that
others have already made,
also internationally, why then with me it's
like the ground is opening up
and you're going into the in  the lion's den of
so this this so
extreme has been increased over the last few years,
of course
also due to my very intensive
intensive life but there
is perhaps also a sign of the times
that this is about the athletes themselves,
you haven't even dealt with
economics yet  Things or something like that with
brands, what clothes do I wear? There have been
times for you, it was
all more like some sort of sound in the
background, it didn't matter you were
really an athlete, it was tennis and
nothing else no no that so I
was always one  a responsible athlete to
suffer from note yes and many others
so I wanted to have a say in what
makes up my life and and I am the
captain of my life here and not you and
and of course we are in a
community and you get a
commission but please let me
decide  where I'll sleep tomorrow and
what I'll do where I'll go on holiday now
but it's always been like that
as a player, it's been like that in my whole
life and maybe that's why
this
fight almost or this discrepancy
between yes, we would like to have Boris,
you say  so and so you are and say I can
please decide about my life so I
am a free citizen and
today I would like to go to the left or
up and even though you think to the right
would be better than my life
and and there right now  Germany,
I notice this loud criticism of
yes, you have to do everything completely differently
and you can do it better and I say
here how do you do everything because when
I see it, your life is significantly more
boring,
perhaps also calmer,
much more treading on the spot
Significantly fewer experiences that a
significantly different view of the world like mine has
significantly less information about how the
world works, that's why
my life is faster, that's why my life is
also more strenuous and of course also full
of mistakes, but who doesn't make
mistakes like that if let me live my life
and in the end  is billed when
you see something fascinating when you
look at who you had contact with,
we already
discussed it on stage in Hamburg, so
you basically launched AOL in Germany
back then as a figure with the
famous one, I'm already in it then  Is there
a story, did you already
say back then that it was somehow an episode
where Jam was actually the
founding of Samba Boris had a hot summer
because you wanted to do something together
then that can't be the case,
but it's about it
and will be
the Philipp behind the
marketing back then.  Your boss today is basically one of the
bosses of Google worldwide,
there are already bigger personalities in
your environment, one person we did
n't discuss in Hamburg, probably
in the end even more successful than the
two of them, namely their Tiriac, so then the
first manager, that's what I have now  I
looked at him in the research and he's
one of the 1000 or 2000 richest
people in the world.
I think he's the richest Romanian with a
bank and an insurance company and an author. He's trading
in Romania, everything under the brats,
tournaments and TV channels and, um, it's
all becoming fascinating now
Over the years I've met here and it's been very clear
who benefited from me
because as young animals I can live my life.
First of all, he was my trainer slash manager.
There wasn't much to manage because
I didn't earn anything, so at 15
16 and there he was  especially my coach
and we have a German coach
who was also known to him from his youth,
a certain Günter Bosch
who also has Romanian roots,
Romanian short, the two can come
from his youth and he was,
so to speak, my companion slash
trainer and  difficult always
had the last word in Germany where the
misunderstood that then Günther
Bosch was the reason why I
won Wimmel so with all due respect and
and and she took the hat off of
Günter Posch's life's achievement no, he
didn't win swimming
orientation, it was me  I
won it and it was the combination that made it
happen and
in fact it was
through me that she was able to conquer Germany, so to speak. She
was intelligent, was always networked
and had a certain amount of life experience and
therefore opened the door to Mercedes to
Allianz and such successful
entrepreneurs  Germany
and once someone is in there and you
give them an hour then you believe
every word they say, in that respect they are an incredibly
intelligent businessman and as
you rightly say, now at 80,
one of the richest Romanians ever,
perhaps still a close friend
for me  Well, I can always ask him
if I
have a question about my life. I'm also friends with his family
and his son, and it's
nice that this
connection has remained, but let's just say that he
has benefited at least as much from me
as I have from him  You can
imagine it straight away because I used to see a tennis game with her,
won the French Open, so
first I have to make it, so I'm really
not at your level now, but I'm already a
very, very big tennis player, um and
then just become a businessman,
that's not the case now  But often,
in the year after your
business separation, he didn't
continue to keep an eye on you. There were people,
Boris, look out here and there or or did
he give you a little advice from a distance?
Don't you have children?
I want to have the break  I have to
do it alone, so alone because I
never did.
After a while, that was 12
successful years, I
continued to play tennis for a long time
and then I teamed up with
a wonderful man and a very
smart lawyer as a consultant  called Dr
Axel Meyer-Wölden I lived in Munich
Earth lived in Munich and then
unfortunately we died much
too early but we had some very good
years where I would definitely
have been together for a lot longer would
n't have been from  In this respect,
even after that, there were always
managers and consultants, perhaps even too
many, who
tried their best, perhaps
not always with their personal best
interests in mind, so it was often about
who is who is more important or who can
benefit more from whom and and have  I
definitely had two or three that
weren't particularly good for me,
so what people
usually think is that I
was resistant to advice, on the
contrary, I claim today that
I had too many advisors and too many
know-it-alls and too many lawyers
and  Everyone wants to get what they want, everyone
thinks so, but you have to do it to the
left or to the right and I think
that I have sorted the field, the list
is very short who can still call me
and because of me I would like to
say something and I think so  That's good for me
because at the age of 55, if I
haven't learned anything from my
last years of work, then
I don't know when and I have a
really great partner and a
very small environment that I trust and
who helps me even in the difficult ones  I have to admit that there were times when
I was in good hands and I want to
believe my basic instinct and my experiences more than I
did maybe 15 or 20 years ago, but where is the
bakery economy understood so you
can Google that is what you believe  I
already Wikipedia in here still
publicly what you earned from tennis games, so to speak,
somehow just
under 25 million, which was then
25 million dollars before taxes
before taxes and costs and before
patients to management, so the number is
reduced enormously and
at the same time there is the statement  I
also think that what I just said directly
said that it was always around 20% of the
total revenue that the bakery brand
generated, so
if you do the extrapolation you can get
a total revenue of because it's not a little
over 200, so yes, that's clear  wrong so that
's not true at all also because
dear John clattering is part of the business
I'm not saying what I've implemented but well below I do
n't want to say anything wrong but be
proud below 50 million makes
[music]
millions have had that's simply
wrong and  Also, the Google doesn't work
every word, that's a very
popular
search system, but not
everything is correct or not everything is up to
date if I've
earned enough money and
you also have double digits in so if
you made investments you know,
so to speak, the famous car dealerships,
I think in Stralsund and and circles
or something like that
then there were a few you can also
see on Wikipedia like this
Lowerian oil well so
if you Wikipedia or otherwise
Google most of it except my age and
my weight  is no longer true but my
age and my name itself is in there
I am the father of three children which is also
not true so if you if you I
will I will
sooner or later really a I have to
bring out a book so that I can tell my
fans or my critics  really
bring you up to date, what did I
earn, what did I lose, what did
I pay in taxes and how did
I get there and that's the
reason for your question, how did I get into
bankruptcy and what do I
still have to pay?  I have to do it afterwards because
this number is really clearly surprising
what I still had in 2017, so
God knows I wasn't poor, so it's
a long story, I do
n't want to get ahead of myself and the book publisher
will also be annoyed if I
watch the days now  I
earned significantly less in like than what's
in circulation so I still know a
little bit about that because of course we
read the things you think how can that be
then you're about 10 million in
the Iranian oil well because of a
business contact in Nigeria and say okay
that's mine  Word so 10 million
never happened,
completely wrong information but it says I
also read it. There were
car dealerships that was
a very lucrative business for me
and the car dealerships sold and it was
a seven-figure business for
me and that went well apropos
Book I wanted that too Do
you have any questions So from my point of view there are
athletes biographies and I like to read them
and I also like to watch documentaries but there
is one that I think is
outstanding and that is the one by
Andre Agassi the open that the book that
read  I have read, yes, you can
also do it several times before, but I also have to correct my
dear friend there,
so that I
neither used my tongue to
show where I was serving,
especially that the tennis court
is 25 meters long, that means there
So he has to hold the magnifying glass in his hand, not the bat,
but the magnifying glass in his hand
to see whether I
open up opinions and then hold the magnifying glass in my mouth
to see where I
point the tip of my tongue
that supposedly is more likely  against you in
various games here were very close
because he could recognize each other's tongues
where would you go on the right so that in
here but also in there so
you were also tough rivals
so yes I think today you like each other
but he also wrote he
Somehow he called you crates because you
were always saying philosophical things like that and back then, by the way, exactly exactly
like that for free and he
also wanted to motivate himself in some way
because that's what you do, you probably do
n't like the opponent, you don't like being able to perform more  It
was also
hard there, very intense or your reality do
you have the greatest respect for his
life's achievements, what he
achieved as a tennis player, namely he
won all four Grand Slams,
Ididn't
and he is one of the few who never
really wins the big one in every tournament  in
the world then of course
with his private decision
to marry our Countess our Queen Steffi Graf
or just two children and and that
that is still the case today so
I think that is a big one, your
greatest victory
and that he managed it  I
just find a way to be
in public sporadically or something like that for professional reasons. I think
he
likes that, so what you
're describing now is his
first marriage to the American
actor and he also writes in the
book  very intensely how that was a problem
and what caused all of this for him in terms of
problems, i.e.
publicity and also other
life goals and things like that, and then he was a
drug addict, i.e. crystal meth
because that was his drug and he also
wrote an open book that he was there for a long time
dependent was such an incredibly great book
but let's just say he also
had his demons and conquered them and
is on a smooth course today and rightly so
and no, we were big rivals because
I was the superstar of the
tennis scene from mid-mid  the 80s
to the mid 90s number of the 90s and
then came others and and had the
spotlight for themselves yes but but
he was successful later than me
although he is not not for younger and
and he only came at the end of the 20s
even 30s  with him in the
sporting success and he thought he had
won heaven at 22, that was only when he came to
me, he won very early on and then he
crashed
so he had a really big gap and
was off the world rankings
and his wife was
also really away from it  Window and
then only came back at the end of the 20s when it was
slowly coming to an end for me, so
we had a lot of matches and yes,
the
older superstar did
n't want to make room for the new superstar or
vice versa and that's when it was admitted  beautiful,
yes, a healthy reality is that is
wonderful in sport is that wonderful
and and that was what we had that was
really fire on the
pitch what I sometimes
miss in sport today I'm somehow too
green and and if I if  Don't
see it and and then there's the
handshake and hugging I do
n't know either who won who lost
so that was our time different you
actually have like a baker and stuff like that
Connors and Ländle and samples or something like that
you saw who won  and who has
lost so those we wore the
reality on our
sleeves we were loudly
busy not insulting the other person
that that was that was okay
and a lot has changed and that's
why others are right in what
he does  claims except with the tongue that
's not true but from my layman's and
fan's point of view I want to say take an
author like that, someone at the flying height who
also understands tennis champion well, that
such a book turned it completely around for me, that
person and read the book
afterwards  Everything is different because it
's not a sports book but it's a
confession of life that's extremely open. He also wore one of his wigs to you
and also yours, his
economic things, which is very
very open to read as you can
actually hardly see the environment but that's how
he gains a lot  I think I'll say he's
authentic, he's open the way he
is and as a rule you at least have
respect for him. You don't have to
approve of everything he's done, but you
respect him and can at least
understand him better why he did this and
that  and
I also have a similar book so he worked on the
book but I found that particularly
interesting and people also
described it critically or had people write about it
from the co-author, Pete central
for example, then he doesn't have much
good hair either  hauptberale and then there is
a passage where he writes that
he would only tip one dollar
even though he is only very rich and so on and so on,
that is also hard
and we are burdensome for both of them
that something like that is in there but we did
that  It's interesting, so they do
n't become best friends anymore, so I
always try to accuse
third parties of it. I could
write ten books. I think I
hold back because, first of all, it
's my story and it's just my
decision who I get involved with
or not and  It's not the
fault of the person or the situation,
but it's my decision
at that moment and I have to
discuss it and
deal with it personally and
then I try to
leave it out. I mean, that's
not the case  heard what
makes of course very good it makes it
exciting so it's almost like
a novel or almost yes but I
also want to as an athlete so I do
n't want to have any bad feelings towards other athletes
I can use examples that is the
athlete is well done  or the
athlete is less good but you do
n't have to say the name anymore we were
back for you first because
the biggest rival
the bigger whale was actually always
myself so the man in the game in the
morning in the bathroom that was my
biggest real and  Then everyone, so I
for myself, the first round was more
difficult than the final
because the opponent in the first round did
n't have to lose, I was the
Skype and would beat me whoever
so now he would have found the meal
and in my second career then too
my business partners
when things aren't
going well for them and they got involved in business with
me then I was
on the headline even though I do
n't have anything to do directly with the business partner
other than the fact that we do a business
together, so that's that  It's also a shame
that it's always my fault when
third parties have problems, so from a sporting point of
view, there's no such thing as I
now remember the
country is Erdberg, she's gone, but that
wasn't the case for you now that
being a person was formative as it was for  Okay,
no, I was always of the opinion that
if I'm in a good mood
then I can beat Ländle and anger
and if I'm not in a good
mood then I can also lose against 17,
so I
really tried to respect every opponent equally,
you would say  In hindsight, you got
everything out of a sporting career
that could have been possible.
No, I loved too much, I
loved
seeing what it looked like on the other
side of the coin and I
had to take care of that when he was
18  Two Grand Slams for years, you
always hated the second world, you have a
little bit of a few likes in the account
that you don't go through
the next 10 years like in the machine computer, I
think it's normal
but it was good for me and it's good for me today
and uh I  I won six Chancellor games
Sex as a coach I would also
like to mention text game I would have had to
achieve two constantly if
I had lived like Jorkovic or
like Viennese there and and but that we are
different type of man with personalities what
you already felt back then that this one
Lifestyle costs success or did
you buy it or say
looking back that that was
worth it to me I was hungry for life I've never been
addicted to drugs I've never been addicted to
alcohol actually I was hungry for life
and just wanted to get to
know the situation in life get to
know people who somehow  I only
go around the houses at night
and that's why I was maybe a
little tired in training in the morning or maybe I was
n't that prepared and
maybe I lost it at times but in
retrospect it was worth it to me. I
think I'm a better
person today because of it, that's you  Also really
interesting and very
differently networked, you can
read about it, so I just know, so I
follow your career. There was a
time when I
lived in the USA myself. There were reports in the USA about
how you were with Didi
somehow in Miami  At the time you were in Pula,
this
patientization actually means
okay, yes, regularly twice, somehow
you spent time again somehow at the
pool talking about life and then
there's the documentary where you meet then you're a
boy then you meet Prince
Albert so there's some sort of support all over the world
Interesting people You have
apparently always had access everywhere
and were looking for Samsung so that the
network of successful athletes,
musicians, actors, myself and
politicians is still astonishing.
Now, when we
meet, we have to hide because
we don't want that  it will
be in the newspaper tomorrow or someone will
take a picture and I've been lucky
enough to get to know great personalities,
interesting personalities in very
private moments who
have given me their trust and I
mean and and that's the
nice side of success or  also the the
the stage so the the the
popularity is just or the
public that you just
know idols and role models privately
also remained friends with someone like that or something like that or I have
no idea
but is there any kind where you that that
is still active I am  more of a
bigger fan of Sean Kader you know like
that yes
so my my direction who I still
really appreciate of course also his
wife wow okay yes and then I'm
a big fan not only of Coldplay
but also of Chris Martin and so on
That's my approach and also
with actors who are
all a bit older now who I think are good but
are also there, say where we both I do
n't want to look at it here somehow
with names but where we both know exactly
what the last ten films were  So
that's still the case, but we
're saving the beginning of the social age,
we have to protect ourselves, we're not allowed to
announce anything, don't say anything because it
can be used against us, are you
sometimes a little
sad to be born so early
and if so  Today you look at what is happening now that
you always have Djokovic or Federer with on
with the shoes and this
collaboration is supposedly very
Federer tennis or entrepreneur is becoming a
billionaire due
to this one collaborations and
then the share that he holds in the company
and which now or  you have the stock market
exactly or have
received unbelievable reviews
with Djokovic, water drop is now also there,
the founder was once a Christian here
in the podcast of an
Austrian company and he
now has shares there, so you would have
shares in potentially large or already large corporations  and
you would have wanted something like that,
you think a little bit, well, say jealously,
man, what
opportunities do they have today and
what would we have had back then, so
I'm basically the opposite of
jealous, so I give it to everyone and I  I'm
happy about the success of others
that's not a German
attribute but I have them and
maybe it will happen to me so
she doesn't want to rule it out so
I'm I have this
business image in my head I know why it
happens like that and  I'm in the process of
building something that is independent
of my daily form and is
about
making an investment in a sensible company,
having a share and also using my
marketing options
to help the company with my marketing experience,
so we're in a lot of good places
Conversations with with exciting
personalities but when I say
there have Federer and Nadal
does that I think and and tokovic
they learned so
in the end that wasn't the case in my generation
that's not possible exactly that was
n't possible but  Nobody thought about
becoming an investor in other companies, they just didn't do that
and then there was the connection with
Pastelli, who invested in an alcohol company,
a golf company, and
thereby gained or earned significantly more money
not
his name at all and he earned his Marie from God
and not with the music, so
the music was a means to an end and
only then did he become famous because of his personalities,
so in his second career he was
able to earn big money, but that was in
my times  20 years ago,
no one did that or if no one was confident about it, there
was also a bit of social media
driven, so now somehow
Federer and and being able to do that is
also a bit dependent on the fact that
they can generate millions of reach
independently, so to speak,
you can do that  So not there was no
social media but I think mistakes I
haven't lost 100 million now
I don't think they have a few million
I just believe that the
Roger Federer brand was young and old
knows and I believe that the
Novak brand is young and old  Knowledge that is
their advantage and that may
also be my chance because the old ones
certainly know me and the young ones know me
better and better because of my very
colorful life, no, but
I think that is important because the old ones are
not
social media only the older ones buy but
that  So what did that say in Hamburg?
What do I think is important, such
a learning to
get to know you, that despite all your success, you were
never driven by money, so there is
a story that you enjoyed playing at the Davis Cup,
for example, for
Germany but then  also with others,
I'm putting the ball down now,
I've seen a bit of research,
um, you could have easily collected the funds
because you were the
German Davis Cup when you played,
it's full of things when everyone is watching, if I was
n't then where that  Then always with
everyone, including the double players and
the reserves, always fairly distributed
and there are a few examples of the fact
that you now have the money,
I would never have had anything like that, but that
would never have fascinated me in the end, so to
my suffering  I was never
particularly interested in money, so in
hindsight it's smarter, but I did
n't play tennis because of money, that was never
a motivational reason if you wanted to
win to become normal, but
I just wanted to win and become one and
whether I then earned something or not was
always secondary  Now I knew how to say,
easy to say, at 17 I already had my
first million but I forgot
some of the prize money so I forgot the check
at the tournament but the
animals just came or in my mother
and all the time we still have to okay, do
you do that? I wanted to win
bad ones  Times and that was my
motivation that was also my
elixir of life. At 25 I didn't do
a test game because of money, I still wanted to
be the best and so
over the course of my career it was actually more and more about doing
good work and
doing a good job  To finish something successfully,
of course we all have to
earn our money and so on but
that was never a priority because how
many I had or no longer have
or now have again has never
interested me, there has to be enough
for my children for my loved ones  and
when that's said to them and I
have a place to stay in my head then I'm
happy and what's in the account is
there 100,000
lifestyle needs to be financed if
that's the same when you say you
're already living internationally somehow
You need a little bit of the world
for that, yes, and if it's not first
class then it's usually economy,
then it's just economy, that's what
I've never been that interested in and if there's
less there then people
eat less or or  the
apartment got smaller and smaller so as long as I
had an apartment and as long as I was
well, especially with my children as long as they were well and then with my wife,
I was always frugal and
have been since today and and that's why these
experiences have of course
woken me up and  harmed me and
I suffered, but not because
I now had significantly less money,
but because my family
isn't doing so well anymore
That was the most beautiful time
is also fuller today or
maybe it's still coming so what were
the most successful years so that was
always my wave so that does
n't have its consequences now either as a
tennis player or as a coach or as a
private citizen or even as a businessman
It was always like that, I ca
n't even tell you the year,
but that was definitely
a time in the 80s, definitely in
the 90s, but I'm feeling
very good again every six months so I know
what it means again  to be free, I
know what it means again, say,
not to have to have sleepless nights.
I think that's an incredible good thing
that I've been able to live again for the last six months
and I'm 55, so I can
still implement something, make a difference in
the next 20  25 years old and to do that
I have to stay healthy, stay clear and say
with the right strategies in the
right team, but I
perhaps appreciate that more today than when
I was 35 or 40 when I definitely
became lazy and and in English they say that they
are complete  so frugal and
everything is okay and so on that's
probably enough even at 40. I
definitely wasn't doing well because I didn't
live out
[music]
as a [ __ ] rather than as a lame duck,
but you have to show something more and more strongly
Of course it was a big mistake.
Today at 55 I'm physically
better than I have been for 10 or 15 years,
but because I take better
care of myself, I'm taking breaks now, I'm
eating better, I'm drinking
significantly less alcohol, I'm doing more
exercise and have  now also privately an
environment that inspires me and
motivates me and note that I want
you to be healthy for a long time to come, so
live better in that respect that's
cool because you can see Instagram you
even have, I think, as part of the tournament
in Stuttgart at the boss above or Munich
knows something  In any case, I
stood on the tennis court again and again and even
hit balls, so I was quite
surprised that this was somehow possible, it's possible
again, so now I say
then my teammates don't play with
me against me then we have a
few changes so exactly big races or
I definitely don't have a sprinter anymore, I
can also hit the ball and I can
always hit the ball faster
and if someone plays with me it's also
a top player so I have it and with
me it's not against me and then I can take
a few more pictures  Hitting I
imagined I didn't see the friendly
movement there, I
immediately remembered it from earlier than from then
actively
from a standing position I can also
serve but please don't ask me
to jump into the court because
I didn't want to do that anymore it's
yours  Coaching career
is actually over now, I mean that's
what I just mentioned myself.
Djokovic is probably the best tennis player of all
time. I do
n't think there are two opinions about it now
because of his successes
trained that's
actually not a bad reference
so I would like to use the word with
most successful and not best with
Jokovic why because I follow you from
lever and from Borg and from Mac and from
Ländle and Edberg and samples and one of my
own here and also from  I do
n't want to diminish my personality, that is, there was
a different time, we had different
competition for a different racket and
different opportunities, which is why
I just want to count you episode of
Novavic and there is without a doubt he is the
most successful tennis player with the
word the best I do  It's difficult for me and
I would have been Nowak's coach for three and a half years now and we
're still very good friends and I'm a big fan so I'd
say I've almost become a member of his family,
which I'm very honored and I
was  Then I was a
national coach for four years, so to speak, as a team leader and I
led the national team and I
trained a lot during that time as a
teenager and also as a younger person
writing material etc. and had a lot of
contact with the German players,
especially and I've been doing that for a few years
So I would
n't rule out the role of coach in
the right situation in the
right moment with a player
who is hungry enough because when I
travel to Melbourne I want to
bring home trophies and not because of that
final then it would be a lost one
Tournament you know what I mean I love
but my my my job and my
job in television I know
I'm doing the first round and I'm
the final and with 14 days in New York
and I really enjoy doing that and that's
why that's  It's difficult
to combine that with a coaching job because
then I would have to play coaching in the few
hours I would have time,
which I think
would be contradictory and wouldn't do justice to the player,
so we still have to
find a solution but it's pretty full
also that you say that
I don't want
to fly around the world at that speed anymore, so to speak. Um, what's
needed is still very
intensive, so what would work?
I would just do the Grand Slams a
couple more tournaments in advance  Is it
limited in time because you're
absolutely right, the trainer's job is
totally there, there are calls at 11 a.m. at night
and 7 a.m. in the morning and so on and so on,
and boss comma, I'm
not feeling so well at the moment and that has nothing
to do with me beforehand  That's how I define a
coaching job, it's a woman of
seven and it's very tiring,
I can do that when I'm watching TV, but
basically in my heart
I love tennis and I love the
sport and I still believe that
I'm young  Players can be taught from
okay, back to aggressive again because
he says yes in retrospect he has or he
hates tennis, he never liked
playing tennis, he was forced to do it by his father
and then he was able to do it well, unfortunately
for him and then it
gets worse and worse  then it
continued in the end um but you love
it already so you commenting is
so much fun you say human then
commenting on a tennis game is
somehow a part of life so I I still
go into the tennis business
um and and I know that's what we have in the  Age
my role and and love this sport
in all its facets I have never hated
it so it was never a burden for me or
I would never be forced to
play tennis so I almost feel
sorry for him that it was like that with him I am
a fervent advocate  the tennis
with all the difficult situations and do
you think that tennis in
Germany
can somehow become relevant again in the future, this time it was
also because of you, among other things, that
is somehow
international other things I think
Spain can do that if there are the stars now  It's
always been there,
now it's relevant again or in
the USA, but not in Germany at the moment,
so you see there's a
possibility of comebacks, which is what
Andreas
says that she says she thinks she
somehow has to
be broadcast by the public then it will happen  always
help and of course you need a
person that's more obvious
what do you think of everything so
I believe that we have
a tennis boma again internationally also in Germany that's why
the commitment
of Sport Deutschland TV the rights
the expensive rights  That's why
Sky's commitment
to have the international tennis rights, but
Eurosport's all great big German
broadcasters,
but you need a local hero, you
need a Zverev
or a Kerber who
can win Grand Slams, who are in the semi-finals
and then this is this one again  The
ignition that is there is then
ignited and then the
tennis tree is gone again and at home I
think the factors are because the
possibilities are the options are
so tangible now it's up to
the artist
to sing the right song  because then the
choir is happy to be there and and and would
like to sing along and let's see you
abroad we'll see you both
internationally ratings are
better today than they were five years ago
and I hope that
's the case in Germany too and that
of course  do you need reach,
of course you need large German
independent channels that are then broadcast in their millions,
but they only watch
if you have the right
personalities in the final and do
you think that the
podcast was I was also a big fan
of it because it was like that too, so to speak  likes to
play for Germany, similar to what you
did, that was also the Olympics
for him so far, I think it was the biggest
and for him personally I think it would be
very big, the Hamburg
tournament has become so it's kind of
cool at the
same time, my layman's understanding is
that Alkaras beats him  In the next few years
no one will be any more
then just understanding is wrong above
all respect no I am now also
for Sascha that he won Hamburg
it was in his city of birth
that people also forget that being born in Hamburg
is a Hamburg and that he is
basically fulfilling his childhood dreams  and
that he has the qualities
to win something and you will be
surprised what will happen to the boom
when
we have him and then he is
again one of the absolute superstars
of German sport and he has the
opportunity and the talent  and I do
n't think that Algarast dominates, yes
he is the successor, he is the new
king, he is the new number one but
I think there are others who have
a say, not just his generation
but also a natural society
but I don't want the Russians either
So absolute world class
is still there then there is a drone
there then there is a Jannik Sinner there
so that the generation of altkaras so there
are many players who
have a say in Virgin who
will win conceptually in the future so who
I know yes there I  I've already
posted it here a bit, it's
so one-sided for me, apart
from the games against Djokovic, the
feeling is that Algaras is
always in a good mood and he's always in a good mood when he's laughing and playing
with them so that's where they are now
fits or that they can
or are that seems
unlikely to me okay he had the
sport of tennis changes every 18 months
that means the locker room does
n't sleep if you are better than
the others, they study you day
and night until they find your
weakness somewhere  find and everyone has weaknesses
and they will then play on them or
fight them and then he will lose
dogs pro and then he will
improve again
and then become stronger again so
when Federer came on the scene he
was invincible until Nadal came and
then it was about suspension
and the same will happen with alcaras
then they will
improve other established ones and the boys
will take a measure of Karas
why is he better now what is he today
and who
will be on the heels of this by next year at the latest  year,
you're right, okay, so that means
consistency in tennis is difficult, the higher it is to
estimate what the
big three have achieved in recent years,
it has never happened before, no, so
that can't be praised often enough,
that's three players
have achieved over  Winning 20 Grand Slam
tournaments each is
n't actually possible and that was only possible
because there were three of them so they
pushed each other up and
motivated each other and then they were at the forefront back
then so they need each other and I
think that will also be a problem  his
for Djokovic that he just does
n't have that anymore for him
Altara's not competition competition is
the history books and he
now always has them on his side he did
n't win 23 plants nor
24 so the motivation for
Djokovic is much more difficult today  when it
was from yes when Nadal stood
up to it and and that makes it so
difficult for the
superstars, say, a long checkered one
if you try to understand your life
or do a little research about it
then there are really
many situations that...  look absurd on the outside,
so I think you were in the
White House, were you received?
I played against the Foreign Minister,
Schulz, his name was there at the time,
but with George Bush senior, he
landed there with his helicopter, so to speak, on the lawn of White House
Played tennis there was
dinner so yes
I wanted to ask there was a moment
that I also thought that could make it
better I think you were at
my European Football Championship in the
German team bus so people did
you go to the stadium to
support them  a bit mentally
so as a tennis player what is say
then in the footballer knew at a
relevant tournament we are talking about Euro
I don't know exactly 96 in England
or something like that so what were the
one and two most absurd moments where you also
said  okay and what good prison
you have to say in a completely different way,
of course absurd and crazy but
what are the two three moments where you
say you're a hungry guy from life
you said
okay now I've got the really big
piece of life's hungry meat on it
Teller no, in fact I was there in 96
at the European Championships in the second week with the
German national team, why
I tore my wrist when you saw them
and my doctor was a certain Doctor
Müller-Wohlfahrt and the physio was an
osteopath  The team is Klaus Eder
and that was my very close one and
then I was friends with
Matthäus and and and and and art and
whatever they were called and I
was their mascot who was
at the quarterfinals of the two. Now
you always have to  ride along and I was in the
team bus in the team cabin
because they were at the final and then I saw
Jogi Löw's speech live in the
cabin 96 but because
sorry sorry
yes sorry I'm waiting we had a
reunion
25 years after the European Championships that was 21 has me
Jürgen Klinsmann, the
captain, invited me and we were there
together with Berti, a Sammer,
and Thomas Berthold in Andi
Möller and the haters and that was the
time and I was there in the dressing room
as Birdy, so to speak, the
decisive one  Words and she
also wanted to have me up in the stands when
they got the trophy from the Queen's
and you
saw that later Masha was so close
because the relationship between me in the
national team and under but that
wasn't probably something  So
friends, yes, that was, that was quite
extraordinary, then my first
meeting with Mike Tyson, yes, that was
always, that came in
1986 in Madison square garden
and he was just 19 and he was the
youngest heavyweight boxing world champion of
all time. I will be the youngest Wimmel
winner  and Larry King and
my friends
dinner was too fat and Mike was
very shy back then and still
looked at his zentella and
wiggled his head like that, so he did it in the ring
and I was always a bit loud and
curious and always wanted to be with Mike
talk and he didn't want to and until then
somehow there was a knife he
dropped and he stared at me like that
again boy and I give you
12 so many times then I stopped
talking to him and understood that
so that was over  I've seen him a lot over the years,
so I really like him,
of course, at the time of Mohammed Ali, I also
met him often in private.
For me, he was an
absolute legend and my favorite
basketball player is Michael Jordan
and, oh, there's a personal relationship, there
's a lot of golf tournaments that we
spent together  and many
weekends so yes so it was like that
was the time and um yes and if you
live in Milan now you live football so
I am yes I am
then I say so I am AC not
Inter and live it out and am close
friends with Paule  Martini, which they
unfortunately celebrated now, but
no one knows exactly why, but Paulo is
my buddy and I like being with the
black and red team in the stadium and yes, I'm
glad that I chose this city. Do
you also follow that in tennis?
There's a bit of this phenomenon
or problem that many
players get so mentally
exhausted or always stop after and
don't come back at all. In the case of
women's Osaka, there are simply more
examples. Men, I don't know what it
's like with the team, but they would also be US Open
winners  So a really
serious injury but it also does
n't really happen anymore, it's
become so hard that you really have to deal with it mentally
or whatever so that mentally
there was just this illness maybe not
this burnout that we
know today, um you can  understand
or where are you? I think that's
a very important topic in our time
[music]
the Americans say mental health. That
expression hardly exists in German
There are no such things in German with the German
language,
so that's a complement for us or
for our lack of knowledge of the language.
I don't know yet, um no, so many young
players or even
musicians or actors ca
n't cope with the so-called pressure  and I
always thought what is pressure, what is
it anyway, so I never had a problem
with it and that's also some of my um
talking you had or if anything as a
speaker is always
about what is pressure at all how can
you combat it how  can you
defeat it how can you
break away from it what a tip so if so it
's a long story
you should yes yes
because that's a problem so they can't cope with
the expectations of the pressure
and fall apart because of it and and use it to take
drugs or alcohol  or
quit your job because you just can't
cope anymore and that never bothered
you so you never
consciously got a problem under control or
was it just that you
luckily never had the problem
because you could free yourself from it
or no so you that is
also in 1985 there was pressure or 90°.  no, there are there are
uh techniques there
are training methods like you
mean these wrong ones that have over pressure you
can train you can train everything
today also you can
train the one correct instead of attitude
you can
train a concentration ability you
can your  Creating an environment
allows the animal to get along better with the maintenance attitude
and that is a big
vacuum for many young people who
simply
have a huge problem with it in today's fast-moving times and then
at some point they have to talk about it  It's
fascinating, that
was never the case with you, so if anyone
had reason to be worried now,
it's because of the last five years. I
really wasn't feeling well,
but I'll give you a
complicated or
tense one, okay, but  In the end it is
a gift or is already a
result of training and that is why
I would judge it wrong and
say to myself that I couldn't
open it because I was born that way, but it involves a lot of training, a lot of
work, a lot of discipline, a lot of
concentration  and the same is
with pressure how do you deal with
this phenomenon what is a phenomenon is
not a reality you ca
n't touch pressure here you can't eat it
you can't drink it but
an imagination
trainer or with a coach and
works  Then about exercises to
deal with this pressure. There are many,
many smart people who
could tell us something for hours. They
have written great books. There are
methods. There are practices that
you can train and then you'll feel
better and you can teach them  Even if
you are a coach,
you told me right away that
you said okay because the first truth and
tennis why you can only concentrate on the
next point is, I
don't think I know, but it starts with the fact
that you start as a layman
Immediately think about the whole game, um, if you
say no, only the next
point is in your head, so as an
example, yes, and the next point does
n't start at 30 15, but it
starts the evening before, there's still
breakfast  it continues as you
hit it, there is an
ongoing scenario where you have to test yourself
how your concentration is and
how you allow yourself to be disturbed and and then
the rush is the next point
but when does the next point
begin that starts in your everyday life  at
that is always always is your next
point because then your next step
your next word your next action
is crucial for the step after that that's
it goes on and on and it's
about awareness, becoming clear,
an ability to concentrate
that you then develop and  Then it's
about the so-called priorities
and you can train that
[music]
Tennis player as a guest I've
already asked that, everyone's talking
about pickelball right now, I haven't seen you
on any of them yet and your document
has certainly been determined by an investor as a head
somewhere  If
you're not a fan, you have doubts about it,
so I'll take a look at the whole thing.
First of all, I'm glad that there are new
forms of play that are honest to the sport of tennis
and pick and battle is
similar to tennis, it's a very social
combinative game so you come in
one  Hour plays really make you
sweat you can hit the ball
you have the best twice and then
you really have two hours of great time
spotty
I want to say that I don't
want to compare it to tennis because
for me it's a completely different sport
but I'm a fan of it  of new
sports and I'm glad that we're
talking about it now and I'm glad that it's also
very popular because it
ultimately uses it for tennis because I
haven't experienced a pick ball or battle
ball fan yet and I'm not a tennis fan
if it's a hipster that helps my calling
and  Um, I've already played paddle.
Poodle can't do that quite well because
I don't run that much, so it
's physically easier for me,
but
it's a beach sport, it's a
bit like that for leisure time, but it will
never have that much relevance  with
tennis as a really serious or
competitive sport, I think it's
much more like a beach sport, so
I think they've found a niche, there are
already
world championships and there's a
ranking list, yes they have their place and it
's deserved,
you shouldn't take part  Compare the sport of tennis
because it is a different language
and do you think that
certain new rules would always be good in tennis or
that you would have to
change the game itself again, especially
when there are now new sports in the
area and new
attention spans in this day and
age  Who watches tennis five hours
earlier than you played there you
have five hours
four hours 42 was that schokovic
and how many million London 12.5
million that was the most watched
tennis game since it was in the final
and Bibis broadcasts worldwide so
we  talk about a billion people
watched these four hours 42 minutes until the end so many times against
arguments that means you say to
shorten tennis in some way
change that you have to stay that's
so I'm glad that we're
getting to the part quicker in the fifth set
at the Grand Slam so with sex both there was
my time there was twelve both
or there was neither that was too long
I would like the Masters
tournaments to be played best of five again in the final
not just two
winning sets but three because it is for
the fan gets better the spectator gets better
and it has more meaning when
you win three sets rather than two
because a long game doesn't mean
the spectators switch off not at all
when it's good the spectators stay
tuned you have to ask yourself how much
tennis tournaments it deserves  have to be broadcast around the
world then he says
every small town yes as well as I have to
but the person responsible for tennis says
are 70 tournaments enough or 90 or does
every tournament have to be broadcast
there has to be the same number of points as
with larger ones so
I would rather do that  question as if
a sentence ends with sex or or only with
four which I think is too short so you
should still play until 6 or sometimes
seven because the whole
100-year-old tradition would be
if I can win with four
two  four three then it's not worth anything have
you followed in golf so that there is,
so to speak, the form of government more or
less with the money there has bought his
own golf live
with Merchant the two yes
but should then have relatively great
relevance in the PGA Tour
tennis  Seems to be suitable for that too,
you can already hear that some
effort is being made to
buy out individual players, a
tournament starts, you look
at it, do you follow a bit of football
and movement in the last four six
weeks, so how much how much Benzema
and  Co or Jordan Henderson for
Liverpool, he is by far the
highest-paid English player and
he was once at 33, so Liverpool's discontinued program
would have been crucial
if it had been in his best years
if he had gone now for
big money but he seems to
prefer to stay in for now  Wanting to play in Europe, yes,
that would have surprised me now. I would be
surprised if you could have
pulled it over that, then
maybe you really would have shifted the focus a
bit,
so it's not for nothing that Messi
always plays Miami, either way,
or by the way, actually, yes, but you
can, you can  you are a footballer or athlete in general
and that the window to
earn money is very thin, it can
be over tomorrow with an injury,
you can really criticize them if they
have received unbelievable offers,
which is why it's
all good to refuse so I ca
n't do it, I want one  Moral questions, yes,
tennis in general is
independent of morality. You decide for yourself
whether it's only in golf. There are also
different opinions and in the end
the PGA was completely against it, now
they did a merger and so on and
you can say it there too  There are
also positive aspects of the fact that this
country wants to open up and take part in it,
so I do, but do you think that that
could happen in tennis? In general, I
wanted to ask the question. Do you see that in
general there is a turn towards
this region and what is happening?  I would
n't be surprised if the current
ATP final took place in Jever two years ago in Turin in three
years.
I wouldn't be surprised by the
women's WTA final so that's it that the
women also offer demand in Saudi Arabia
and I don't want to
criticize anyone
I think it's absolutely correct to always
offend, and that's just a
sign of the times.
Golf was the first
football to step up when Ronaldo
went to Saudi Arabia, they weren't
criticized to death for half a year today,
I think everyone is doing it  It's great
that Messi went to Inter Miami
but he doesn't do it from
appenhai either so he also gets his
own so I really think
supply and demand
we athletes shouldn't be political
and and because when he starts then
in which country can you  we still have to
play when the government starts
to implement it, so then things get thin with
the map, we can still play that's
why we have to
be political and we have to
pursue our careers and if the offer
in Saudi is bigger than in Finland
or in because they don't  in Australia
then you have to go home
at the same time there are already and then
the sport takes away the right
the Russians, for example, are
not allowed for a year and what happened
that the ATP
points were distributed then it was a
bit and the  The tennis community
decided on a very small scale that we are above all
athletes and not
ambassadors for our country and that we
will compete at the US Open with our name
and not with our flag. That is
the right decision for me and
this year Russians and Belarusians were also allowed to
play in Eyelashes again
Which I think is right,
we've also clarified it,
so you've just
opened the door for me. If a book comes out, then there
's usually a
sequel or new questions, let's say
the ones I rarely do, but I
have respect for you and a good one too
Feeling thank you very much for
being prepared and then I'll give you a
little bit of information about what really
happened and not what supposedly
third parties are claiming, who no longer
have any idea about my life and
I think I
put two headlines saying
oops that  What's next so I
'm glad we saw each other, me
too, I'm excited now I'm
in New York myself, you
're there too, so let's see what exactly
or well,
thank you very much, ciao